it's crazy because like back in the day
when you were playing obviously they
would be testing for weed right so like
marijuana was frowned upon in the league
and what were what were were you
actively smoking yeah man I smoked my
whole sauce I started smoking uh
like eighth grade to ninth grade summer
so that was your starting point you
smoked throughout the whole your whole
so what were ways you were dodging the
tests um so when I first got in the
league like they used to do one team
drug test in the preseason so they would
test everybody in one day
was what it was everyone knew to you
know stay clean for that test and then
you could you know [ __ ] had
blunts or joints in the car since we got
done with practice that's amazing
um but then it did you know it started
it went to four random so it was just
like a real job to stay so I would
always stay up like maybe every six to
eight months I would stock up on these I
would go to go to I can say it now
because it's not legal so I go to GNC
and I just tell them like yo
and they'd always recognize it like
what's the best uh drink to clean out
you know the detox stuff yeah I'll be
upfront with them and it was never [ __ ]
that was out but everyone could see no
my cousins are on probation used to
always have to go and get that [ __ ] and
then drink a bunch of it so it was
always underneath the counter so like my
test day so I used to uh pay my trainers
a little bit of bread it just kind of
gave me a heads up like hey uh you know
because at first they would say the
names so we would really know who's
coming you know but later they just it
was when they were coming they wouldn't
say who was getting tested till you got
there so every time I got that morning
call which everyone would get the
morning call like hey drug test today
you know be ready uh name you get the
names you get here I had to prepare like
as if
um it was me so even though it wasn't me
every time I had to prepare and that
[ __ ] and stuff like you had to wake up
hella early drink this whole little
thing and it's nasty as [ __ ] and then
drink like three or four Waters and just
keep peeing like you had to pee like
three four or five times and then once
you pee that much like you're
your [ __ ] is uh kind of a
uh it's clear like you have a window of
like how long it's you know your pee is
clear like six to eight hours it's crazy
it's crazy because like I never thought
as a kid you'd see the day where like an
active NBA player like KD right it's
like involved in a marijuana company
well that's what I said uh you know like
a lot of people took a lot of chances
you know I got caught twice you get uh
caught three times you're suspended for
five games and everyone knows about it
so I got caught twice in my 15 years and
but also like you're allowed to admit
yourself to the program as well if you
know you're gonna fail one time I didn't
have my drink and they got me I was just
I was slipping so I called the dudes
right there like yo I'm about to get
tested and I know I'ma fail and they'll
allow you to come into the rehab program
and you gotta oh God think about all the
money the NBA took from people back then
but there's people in his careers on the
flip side they'll you know they'll shoot
us with Toradol they'll give us any kind
of painkiller we can ask for as much as
we need and I'm sure football's even
worse and it's just like they they want
to pump Us full of that but but not the
actual anti-inflammatories that aren't
addictive they want to find us
suspenders and some people lose their
career you know over something that that
can help us now that something is that's
legal now as well yeah because if you
think about the downside of any
painkiller it's
it's masking one thing and and causing
problems in another area you know what I
mean so it's just that temporary get you
back out there relief that that they
need to make money